ukrainian troops are retreating from the
eastern city of seville donetsk after
weeks of fierce fighting against
invading russian forces a regional
official said ukraine's units would move
to stronger positions
recent days have seen russia make
significant gains around the strategic
eastern city russia is trying to
encircle ukrainian forces and seize the
entire donbass region
local ukrainian officials say the
fighting is intensifying and nowhere in
the east is safe anymore for residents
for more on this let's cross over now to
the ukrainian capital kiev where dw
correspondent nick connolly is standing
by nick ukrainian forces we just heard
beginning to pull out of severo donetsk
is this a sign that kiev admits defeat
at least when it comes to this region
i think it's definitely an acceptance
that civil donetsk was not a city that
ukraine could hold on to with acceptable
losses for any longer it is quite
extraordinary though how long ukraine
has stayed in control the city experts
have been talking about the city being
taken by the russians for basically the
best part of a month now and the
ukrainians just kept on holding on kept
on forcing the russians to basically
lose huge numbers of soldiers to invest
a huge amount of firepower pulling away
weapons and
resources from other parts of the front
lines just to gain a couple of streets
at a time
and now in a situation where several
nets is basically the only ukrainian
stronghold on the northern side of that
severity river where the bridges behind
them have been blown up ukraine has now
said that they are going to try and pull
the people out how they're going to get
them out without bridges without a
situation where there are pontoons we
don't know but that seems to be the plan
now
and yeah it's a blow but i think it's a
situation where ukraine basically tried
to do the same as it did with mario paul
to
turn this into a pyrrhic victory for the
russians a hollow victory where they've
basically invested more resources than
that city is worth
but they obviously are desperate for
some kind of victory some kind of gain
because overall now in our fifth month
of war the russians have pretty little
to show given the huge resources and
given their huge uh superiority in in
firepower to show for all their efforts
nick do we know where the new positions
of the ukrainian forces are or will be
so the expectation had been that it
would be listed chance which is
basically severed in its sister city
just on the other side of the riverbank
uh which has kind of a geography
topography that would make it easier to
defend because you've got high river
banks and lots of
ways to basically shoot at people trying
to get across that river but we have
seen now in recent days the russians
trying to come atletic from the other
side from the south in a way that would
avoid them having to cross that river in
the past we've seen the ukrainians
really inflicting huge damage on russian
attempts to cross that river in other
places so a sense that maybe the
ukraines will have to draw back a little
further but if you just zoom out and
look at the bigger picture these are
still pretty small movements over a much
bigger front line the ukrainians are
facing off against the russians over
basically 2 000 kilometers of territory
and overall ukraine is still in control
of a big chunk of donbass it lost most
of the ground in their first weeks of
the war when it was basically
overwhelmed swamped with attacks all
across the country and now in recent
weeks those movements really haven't
been that big so yes it is a tactical
withdrawal but in the bigger picture um
ukraine is still holding on to its main
centre's main cities in that part of the
country and it's basically trying to
minimize its losses now
unlike the russians where we've seen
pretty significant willingness to do
pretty risky military maneuvers that
have cost the russian soldiers lots of
lives oh i do double use nick connolly
they're reporting from kiev thank you so
much
thousands of people have rallied in the
georgian capital tbilisi to show their
support for the former soviet republic
joining the european union protesters
are angry that eu leaders this week
refused to grant georgia candidate
status they're calling on the georgian
government to resign or implement the 12
points listed by the eu for its
application to be reassessed
now the european union's decision this
week to grant ukraine candidate status
marked what brussels called the
beginning of a long journey that the two
sides would walk together but supporting
ukraine will come at a cost for europe
in the form of soaring energy prices
dw's christine mundo reports
by the time the eu's 27 heads of
government began day one of their summit
it was all but certain that they would
announce the decision to grant ukraine
candidate status for eu membership a
first step in a long process that puts
kev on the road to brussels the
importance of this decision for ukraine
cannot be overstated it is the european
union saying to the embattled country we
want you with us just imagine how much
of a boost that is to the ukrainians
fighting on the front lines but it was
also important for the eu's leadership
who desperately needed a show of unity
and to send a message to moscow that the
entire eu was still strongly in support
of ukraine and its aspiration to join
the west
but there is economic trouble in the
west and that dominated day two of the
summit's agenda
inflation is a major concern for all of
us
russia's war of aggression is pushing up
the price of energy foods and
commodities and all of this has a direct
impact on our citizens and businesses
the eu has sought to isolate russia for
its invasion of ukraine and since the
war broke out the bloc has delivered six
rounds of sanctions targeted at russia's
economy
eu leaders say moscow is retaliating by
restricting gas supply to the eu by now
it's 12 member states
that either have been totally cut off
the russian gas or partially
and therefore the best is always hope
for the best prepare for the worst
that's what we're doing right now
the worst case scenario is russia
completely cutting off all of its gas
supply to europe
the impact of that would be devastating
for member states like germany and
others whose economies depend on
russia's energy